[Music]
good morning everyone
welcome to the day two of our virtual
conference a paradigm shift
in infectious diseases lessons from a
pandemic
my name is vivujan i am head of
commercial marketing for asia pacific
for mark research solution business
i am the moderator of today's module on
diagnosis
and innovation during pandemic
i would like to introduce our first
speaker dr
anne wiley from yale school of public
health
and will share with us about her latest
work on
saliva direct kovit 19 diagnostic test
this test got emergency approval from
fda couple of weeks ago
please put your questions to end in the
chat box
over to un hello i'm pleased to be
joining you today and able to share our
work on saliva direct
saliva direct received its emergency use
authorization from the fda on august
15th
and has been described as the most
unique eua that the fda has issued to
date
what makes this alive direct different
is that we haven't developed like a test
kit we're not manufacturing anything
we're not distributing anything
other than the method itself so the eua
that we have
allows us to designate other labs who
can also get saliva direct up and
running in their own labs for testing
so saliva direct really came about from
this main goal that we had to improve
testing options
we've been collecting samples from
covert 19 and patients since the start
of the pandemic where
we're enrolling these patients and to
collect a variety of sample types from
them
as a way of studying both south kobe 2
but also trying to understand more about
covert 19 disease progression
and right from the start of this we
experienced a number of different
challenges
and some of the more major ones coming
from the nasopharyngeal swab itself
we experienced firsthand the supply
chain issues and trying to get these
swabs and
having to order our own tubes and making
our own viral transport media and
putting these kits together
there's of course the discomfort that it
can cause
patients which also carries risk to
healthcare workers if the
patient has to like sneeze or cough on
the healthcare worker
and we're seeing a lot of testing
aversion as people learn more and more
about how uncomfortable these swabs are
and i think we also missed out on a
number of research opportunities because
um
of either not having enough swabs for
the research swab and not wanting to
detract from the
um diagnostic supply chain but also from
the healthcare workers just
understandably being concerned about
going in for a second swab so first
having to take that diagnostic swab
and then having to put themselves at
further risk by taking that second swab
for research purposes
um for rna extraction so all the swaps
that all the samples sorry that we're
coming through
um again we'll collect in a variety of
samples so being the nasopharyngeal swab
oropharyngeal swab
blood samples um saliva fecal swabs
um these will all be in process for rna
extraction so we were trying to detect
sars kobe too
and regardless of what we were saving
them for um we decided that would see
the presence of stars kobe 2 in each of
these samples and for that we were using
an rna extraction
method again we were very keenly aware
of supply chain issues when setting this
up so
we actually started off by using a kit
that wasn't um
already recommended for the clinical
diagnostic testing and it soon became
one of the
recommended kits um but you know so
we were aware again of these the supply
chain issues
also this was sort of the most time
consuming step and also the most
expensive part
of um the sales kobe 2 detection
we were testing all of the rna um in rtq
pcr
so we were using the cdc's primary probe
primer probes um
for n1 n2 and rp as the human control
we were just ordering these separately
from idt um but again like every sample
that we extracted had to be run in these
three different
rtq rtq-pcr reactions which was also
quite a labor-intensive
step so these of all those issues that
we were seeing
with the nasopharyngeal swab that's why
saliva really caught our attention so
we were as i said we were just
collecting these samples and these
matched samples from these covert 19
inpatients so we had a whole range of
matching nasopharyngeal swabs and saliva
samples
taken from the same patients at the same
time points
and as we were watching the um results
of sars kirby 2 detection coming on by
we started to see that saliva was
looking quite promising that we were
seeing
that it was acting as good as or even in
some cases better than
and the detection of phosphorus cov2 as
compared to the nasopharyngeal swab
so for that reason we decided to keep
working with um
saliva as a sample type and see if we
could help validate it and optimize it
further for
um as a testing specimen so as we were
starting that work to validate saliva as
a sample type
there was some early pre-prints that
caught our attention where people were
taking the viral transport media from
swabs
and testing that almost directly in pcr
and we couldn't help but wonder you know
could we do the same with saliva so it
um really did stem from quite just a
crude test very early on where
i was setting up a qpcr anyway and
thought what happens if we just put some
saliva
into the master mix and get it running
like will we see anything
and it wasn't the greatest result but
they were encouraging enough
for our scenarios to like um pursue this
further and i think our previous
experience was working
with saliva as a sample type put us like
quite in a nuke position to be able to
develop this
we knew that if we could add protein hk
to saliva samples this would really just
help um
really helps cut through a lot of the
mucus and makes it a lot easier
to work with um but of course can also
like break down
the proteins in the virus helping to
expose it so we found that by
just simply taking a saliva sample
adding protein sk
combining it and in the heat and
activation step at 95 degrees for five
minutes
we could get rid of that whole rna
extraction process
going on to the rtqvcr detection we also
realized that if we could just do one
simple reaction rather than the three in
singleplex that would also save us a lot
of time and effort
so we duplicate the n1 and the rp so
again we've kept the rp in there as
a human control it's to um so that we
can be sure that if
your sample is negative for n1 you're
not getting a false negative
due to some sort of inhibition in the
sample itself and that the reaction
didn't actually
work so targeting in one full-size kobe
2 detection
targeting an rp to make sure that the
samples have got enough quality
and they added benefit of taking out
that rna extraction step
it is the most expensive part of the um
process
it also saves us some time so in our lab
it takes it can save about an hour
we're thinking that in instances where
you know automation might be in place
this can also save a lot of um
hands-on time from personnel who have to
maybe move um
plates between different automations and
seconds just sort of get prepared for
rtq pcr immediately so
one of the other key things that we're
doing with saliva direct is that we're
just having a very very simple saliva
collection process
so we are just simply asking um patients
study participants
to simply just pull saliva naturally in
your mouth you know you're not supposed
to cough anything up sniff anything back
we don't want any of that sort of really
thicker more mucus-y saliva we just want
that normal true saliva that just
just pulls in the mouth and what we
found is that you can actually just very
gently expel the saliva into a tube
and that we don't actually need any
preservatives so there are
some quite expensive saliva collection
devices that are out there in the market
i mean these can range anywhere from
sort of seven dollars fifty ten dollars
fifteen dollars all the way up to fifty
dollars per
um saliva collection device and you know
if you wanted to do a lot of repeat or
frequent testing
that can greatly add up over just you
know even a small number of tests
so it's quite important for us to see
like how stable
size kirby 2 detection was in saliva
without any of those expensive
preservatives for our fda eua we
performed a spiken experiment so we took
a very strongly positive saliva sample
and we diluted it down in negative
saliva so that would reach
12 25 50 virus rna copies per microliter
we stored each of those aliquots for
seven days at four degrees room
temperature or 30 degrees
before extracting them through saliva
direct and comparing it to the ct values
that we had
when the samples were processed fresh
and as you can see we had just very
stable detection
even after seven days um in each of
those conditions
we've also seen this in clinical samples
however so
um panel a the graphene panel a um
basically the lines of dots that you see
so each of the dots that are joined by a
dotted line represent the same sample
and in panel a we first of all have the
ct values so the size kobe 2 detection
when the samples were processed fresh on
the day that we received them
and then we also have the ct values from
after a free thorough cycle
but then also after they've been
incubated at room temperature for five
days or 30 degrees for three days and
what we can see is we can see that it's
very quite stable
detection of size kobe 2 just in the
saliva
nothing else um and the panel b
graph um that just really shows that
these were samples that we left out for
longer
um just at room temperature and and
one of the ones towards the bottom there
that's going out all the way to 25 days
well just very stable detection just in
saliva
at room temperature so for us this is
what's helped us to keep
prices down for saliva direct and making
it just very easy um
many just sort of like very simple
laboratory plastics that you can use to
collect the sample
what was also important for us to
establish was that this method would
have maintained sensitivity
um so again we started developing this
really quite early on when
you know the most sensitive method
really um that we knew of was
rtq pcr detection and i think very early
on i was
absolutely terrified about what a
false negative could mean um you know we
didn't i didn't really understand or
know what was that risk of those very
very low viral loads
so you know we worked really really hard
to make sure that we were developing
saliva direct we could get it as
sensitive as possible
as compared to that method with the rna
extraction
so this is just a graph of some of the
clinical samples during our development
and you can see that compared to having
rna extracted
or going through the saliva direct
method and we did maintain a good level
of sensitivity
there is one i mean we lost a detection
of two samples one is near that lower
limit of detection
the other one is slightly higher but
that was actually a really good learning
point for us as well because
that sample is around 30 ct
and then was negative and slightly over
direct it turned out that it was
actually a sample that was really really
quite
mucusy it came from quite a severely ill
individual and just being that quite
you know it wasn't that normal true
saliva it was very much more it was more
sort of almost like sputum to some
extent
um and the fact that there was so much
more sort of
um yeah it really we found that it was
inhibiting
um the qpcr detection and i think that's
what
it was a good learning point for us and
that we needed this just to be good
true proper saliva um nothing thicker
nothing um more difficult to work with
either
this was also our development for the
multiflex pcr
so um again we've been using the
singleplex for n1n2 and rp
and actually originally we decided to
try and multiplex all three of these
together into a single reaction
um and in the end we decided to take
into out just because for us in one
detection for size curvy two has been
just remarkably stable very
um specific very constant whereas we see
a little bit of variability in n2 and
actually including n2
it led us to a lot more sort of invalid
samples so
we sometimes often see like a larger
discrepancy between n1 and n2 detection
and so we just thought for
saliva duret to keep it more simple to
help improve our results
just to go for the dualplex in the end
of just n1 and rp
what's really also quite unique about
saliva direct is
again as i said we're not packaging
anything up we're not selling anything
we're not distributing anything
in fact we're getting all of the labs to
go direct to the vendors
what we've done is that each step of the
way we've validated reagents from
different vendors and we're going to
keep expanding on this further
we wanted to do this to hopefully
circumvent any supply chain issues
and also to hopefully keep um
competition between the different
vendors um so that you wouldn't see any
sort of price increases due to sort of
the recommendations that we're putting
forward
so through these different combinations
and
the list price of a saliva direct test
is about 1.30 to 4.30 for just three
agents um
however a lot of labs already have a lot
of existing um discounts or you know
bulk discounts that you can get through
the suppliers so
in a number of cases we think that you
can actually achieve about one dollar
per sample for the reagents itself
now we are aware that um there are other
costs that do need to go on to this so
of course um
costs for the logistics um for um
obviously the personnel to run the test
the facilities to help these tests and
a lot of the regulatory steps as well um
can be associated with some quite high
prices so
we do know that it is going to be more
expensive to run saliva direct than just
this one dollar per sample
but i think what we really wanted to
highlight is just how cheap it is
at the base of it and therefore you know
this will hopefully really make the
difference like this should not be a 100
or 150
test but really more affordable
so using those different combinations um
we've
validated um the limit of detection for
each of those various combinations so
this is just showing
um an example of our limit of detections
um graphs so in this in the instance of
these three graphs we were just
um changing out the master mix so we're
keeping the protein sk
and the instrument constant in this one
and just changing out the
between the neb luna the bio red
reliance and the thermo tech path master
mixes
regardless of any of the combinations we
achieved
we were getting down to about six to
twelve coffees per microliter
and that sunpower was you know a number
of the great pcrts out there at the
moment
and you know and as you can see from the
grass we were only going down to six
copies per microliter we weren't
actually going down any lower in the
sort of dilutions that we had done
and then recently um especially under
the fda's advice
is that we've made an extra step down to
three copies per microliter
and actually when we've been re-running
some of these for our bridging essays so
far
we are finding that we can get down some
of the combinations down to three copies
per microliter so
a good level of sensitivity there
so one of the things that we had to do
of course was the clinical validation
um so the first thing we did was we had
the um
matched mesopharyngeal and saliva
samples from covert 19 patients
so we first had to validate saliva
itself as a sample type
so we tested both the nasopharyngeal
samples and the saliva on the thermofish
attack path covered 19 kit
and um again we had 94 sensitivity as
compared to the swabs so
you know there was one sample that was
positive in the nasopharyngeal swab but
negative in saliva
but actually there were a few samples
that were negative by the nasopharyngeal
swell that were positive in the saliva
for the clinical validation of saliva
direct itself we took those same saliva
samples
but then we ran them through the rna
extraction free method of saliva direct
and we um compared those results to the
nasopharyngeal swabs and again
we had 94 sensitivity
we also did a quick check on cross
reactivity so
um i mean we were already using n1 so we
weren't too concerned about a risk of
false positive
detection simply because n1 is already
so widely
um used in tests throughout the country
at the moment um and
you know people continuing to do in
silicon analysis analyses
it's been tested against a number of
different viruses and bacterial species
but we had saliva available to us that
was collected um prior to covert 19 so
we just thought well
we have these saliva samples that were
collected locally let's just run them
through
um saliva direct and just really make
sure that you know just as a
just a bit more reassurance that we
weren't going to have any cross
reactivity and again
um yeah really nice clean results there
there was no sort of cross reactivity
and in one so no
evidence of false positive detection
there
so in summary we've received this
emergency use authorization
our main goal originally was to reduce
testing costs we wanted to make testing
accessible across the country we know
that we knew that repeat
testing was going to have to be required
in order to sort of reopen
and to get a handle on the virus and we
really wanted to develop a test that
could
drive these test prices down so we could
increase the number of tests
in the community and we also wanted to
um
reduce implementation time by using
saliva and just having this very very
easy to collect sample type
and that people would be more happily um
and ready to do so
and just sort of removing that reliance
on the supply chain of swabs
so the key points really about eua to
also note is that again this is a
protocol
and it's not just an ldt as a protocol
that we are able to distribute to other
um to high complexity clear labs for
them to implement this
uh locally we are going to continue to
um perform bridging studies
so we're going to um make sure that we
uh bridge on more reagents just so that
we can avoid supply chain issues and
we're going to bridge on more
of the pcr instrumentation just so you
know we don't want
people out there having to run out and
buy new pcr instrumentation we'd rather
do a bridging study with those
labs to get those um existing pcr
instruments up and running um we also
make no profit again we
aren't selling this is a method we're
not selling a kit we're having
individuals go directly to the lab and
to the suppliers and order the reagents
from there
so for anyone looking for more
information on saliva direct we do have
a web page up and going
um we do also have which can link to our
fda eua
the pre-print that we've prepared which
we go into some of our results and our
findings in greater detail
and we also have a um form available for
clear labs who are interested in
applying for
authorization to uh use saliva direct
so while we've come up with this method
this is definitely not where we're
ending with saliva direct i mean we
there is such a
urgent need i mean it's been it's been
really inspiring um
so many people have reached out to us in
response to this and we've had so many
labs reaching out to us wondering how
they can get up and running and
i think what's also been inspiring about
that is because we've made um
the fact that we've made test prices
such an important conversation and all
of this and still labs
knowing how much we're saying that this
test should be running through for
labs are still coming to us and ready to
sort of um work with us and work on
bringing their pricing down and help
make testing more accessible
it's also been quite equally moving
though seeing the number of schools
um schools local groups universities
also reaching out to us
um desperate for twist testing options
and where they can get testing
so we're hopefully going to be on the
website updating the list of the claire
labs that we do
authorized to use to live direct so
we're also hoping that that will be a
way that these local groups can also
connect with labs and find more testing
options
we do realize though that we do need
better testing options and more testing
options
and ideally if we can move away from the
lab and from pcr
what's been i think one of the most
exciting things for me about receiving
our eua
is that it's been this unique eua
and the idea that you know there are so
many other tests out there
in development at the moment and we are
having to see this shift in this way of
thinking about testing where we're going
to move away from this idea of
diagnostic testing
and more into these tests that become
important for screening and surveillance
and i'm just hoping that that you know
we have managed to get this sort of more
new more unique eua
means that i'm really hoping that other
um many of the other great tests that
are in development at the moment out
there
will also start um being able to get
euas
or yeah get um authorized more easily or
quickly to expand our testing options
further
so thank you very much
thanks anne for a great presentation and
staying awake for so late in the night
for this conference
hi everyone this is heather can you hear
me
yesterday hi
i'm sorry we're having a little bit of a
technical difficulties but i'm going to
go ahead and
start the questions here so um the first
one that i see
coming up is that i um just i wanted to
comment on
i like the direction you're taking with
the bridging studies
it relates back to a question that came
up yesterday in terms of collaborating
across the public and private sector
um can you comment have you been
approaching and collaborating and how
this may have been impacted
by the pandemic um if anything the
pandemic has just been
such an incredible source for
collaboration i've just been
so incredibly inspired by the number of
you know research institutes but also
industry partners that just come
together and have been
so open and transparent with the work
that is being done and
you know the difficulties that we may
have been having or um suggestions to
help each other i just
you know it's been this is not really
the time that we should be sort of like
squirreling away secret research you
know if we want to sort of
get this pandemic under control you know
coming together to work together and
being
open with everything we do that's how
we're going to really make progress on
that so
um that's been really encouraging and
yeah with the bridging studies um
you know we obviously don't have access
to all the different pcr instrumentation
people have so
we've been asking people to let us know
what they have and so we can also keep
an eye on what other labs have and
i think um even today we just shipped
some of our samples out for validation
so we're going to have some people
validating a few different of the other
um at the quant studio machines for us
and just so that we can get them onto
the eua to help other labs get up and
running as well
oh that's fantastic um just inspiring um
i love the approach um i know that we're
getting questions that are coming in
um really i love this just
opportunistic um
you know everybody wanting to get
forward faster
in terms i have another question here
too um in terms of can you comment on
your plans um
to increase the thorough put so if we're
looking at um
you know high throughput 384 well it
can you maybe comment i know you have
different platforms but comment on you
know your future plans there
yes indeed so some of the samples that
we've sent out for the validation and
the bridging studies today they are for
384
um well platforms because again that was
something that we didn't have but we
know that others do
we're also reaching out to labs we know
that there's a number of automation
systems out there you know we're a tiny
little research lab you know we've been
doing everything manually by you know
manual preparing
but it'd be really great if we could
transform this onto you know some of the
hamilton robots just to really increase
and sample throughput so again um
looking
to work with people on that
okay so we're getting um that's
fantastic we're getting a couple of
questions in here in terms of um
i'll take it in two parts so i asked the
first one so is there any pre-treatment
um
in terms of the saliva as part of the
process or is that direct
um i mean in in a way the only preacher
so i guess yes and no i mean the only
pre-treatment per se that we're doing is
that simple treatment with protein as k
and protein sk is just something that
we've found it's really
um the reason helps cut through any of
the slightly thicker samples you know it
helps to
make the sample easier to prepare it
also um probably helps to start breaking
down the virus and opening that up and
then
that's just followed with that simple
five minute uh step at 95 degrees to
essentially
inactivate the protein sk just before
that goes into um
actually qpcr i know some labs have been
a bit worried about
um opening the samples um and so looking
for heat inactivation steps
um you know we're doing this in a bsl2
lab so that's not been
um too much of a concern for us but we
are aware that
others are worried about this so we are
going to sort of also validate on
some of those pre-treatment heat steps
that people have been using just to show
that this doesn't have
an effect on downstream detection
perfect thank you okay that i'll i'll
ask the second part of that question and
it's really a pivot in terms of the
previous treatment but more of it
kind of struggled that word but um what
else you know do is there a limitation
in terms of
the the methodology um they're asking
about you know could you use it for drug
testing
um like drugs of abuse um you know other
um infectious diseases there limitations
that you
you know can think of or is maybe
comment about a comment about
you know what you kind of see this path
forward
yeah so indeed so um live direct was
really developed for sales cov2
detection so i'm not actually in the
uh i haven't done too much else in terms
of like drug testing or anything like
that so i'm not sure what would need to
be done
for that but what we do hope is
definitely to expand this
we would like to expand this forum
detection of other respiratory tract
viruses so especially you know going to
flu season
and the fact this is a dual plex pcr if
we could get some primers and probes in
there to make it multiplex for sort of
influenza a and b um or other many other
common viruses
um so that we could you know test
straight away for is it south kobe 2
is it influenza is it something else um
yeah we're looking to expand it for that
okay thank you um i think we're just
about time with um
at our our time for q a but what i'd
like to do now is just thank you so much
for joining us
um this afternoon and we've really
enjoyed your presentation and
as part of um the third theme uh so
thank you anne and
um and we're gonna go back into our
other presentations
thanks for having me